oh
yeah all right there she is it's just
it's about the lady herself
right not about it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
what just
[Music]
she's coming she's coming there bro it's
about to go down
welcome back to new rockstars loki
episode 2
just ended by confirming loki's sexual
fluidity
in the sexiest way possible revealing
lady loki
is using dozens of stolen tva reset
charges to
bomb the sacred timeline but who
is she and what is her plan or should we
say
wait a day damn a minute
this is inside marvel new rockstars loki
after show i'm eric boss my easter egg
breakdown of the episode's coming out
later today but here right after
watching the episode
we're here with mt oh boy oh man what an
ending to that episode eric holy [ __ ]
lady lucky evening she was working
towards something crazy but
we couldn't have imagined on this scale
oh no it's amazing
she is wrecking the timeline straight up
well in this episode the fugitive loki
variant uses mind control to kidnap a
chrono monitor from a ren fair in 1985
and then while it's going on loki is
joining mobius on this investigation
they actually at one point debate the
whole absurdity of their respective
belief systems
they talk about jet skis you know we
gotta end this series with owen wilson
on a jet ski show oh my god
please that's how it ends the last shot
owen wilson on a jet ski
right final shot just drifting off into
the sunset that's what i want
maybe loki can be hugging him from
behind you know just get a nice
luca hug there we get that it's a hard
cut to black and then we get
owen wilson will return
just owen wilson not mobius is owen
wilson yeah just owen wilson
he'll be a variant playing some other
characters let's yeah lightning mcqueen
but the the big reveal of this
investigation is that this fugitive that
they're chasing has been hiding in
apocalypses throughout history they
proved this by going to pompeii in 7980
right as vesuvius is erupting
uh and loki reasons that whatever
branches would get formed by the result
of that variant being there would just
get erased by the
apocalypse wiping everything out they
are able to triangulate the next
location
using that kablooey gum uh to the
roxcart store which is basically like an
amazon shipping center
amazon store of the future just a
terrifying like a
massive corporation that runs this town
uh and a very bleak future of future
superstorms wiping out coastal towns in
the gulf
it's only 30 years away sounds pretty
accurate to me
as this hurricane is hitting and this
locus loki reveals herself as
lady loki at least we think that's going
to be your name but it's pretty clear
it's lady loki
sophia dimartino is acting her and uh
she has been using these stolen tv reset
charges
and stolen uh portal gateways to send
these reset
charges throughout the sacred timeline
causing all these branches these chaotic
branches
if you look closely it looks like all
kinds of marvel planets like everything
that the mcu has set so far
is on that list including the ego zandar
vermeer asgard it's all there
yeah and the easter egg breakdown i'll
list exactly every date and what that
could mean
but here we just got to really talk
about what lady loki is planning
um i think that's the central question
here what's the next step
uh before we get to that be sure to
check out our new latest obsession shirt
loki out of time these are flying off
the digital shelves over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
uh i don't even know if i'll be able to
get one to wear in videos
uh hopefully they're so good yeah
they're so
good so freaking yeah there's an entire
loki collection actually
um in addition to this shirt there are
other loki shirts including this
augmented reality shirt
uh loki prints cell phone cases a miss
minutes stickers
wall clock that mt has graciously
allowed us to uh to feature
despite his romantic attachment to her
my wife
you know my wife started funny it
entered an uncanny valley of not being
funny for a decade and then now it's
kind of now we're back funny again
yeah we've reclaimed my wife
um but the uh this the collection looks
amazing be sure to get your hands on
something because it directly supports
this channel
uh and uh also of course by getting the
loki out of time shirt the best thing
about it
is you're gonna get the ability to
additionally write in a custom
shout out that we're gonna feature at
the bottom of the screen during these
after shows
and just to read a couple here jake
phillips said i told my boss that if i
am late for work it's okay because the
tva will just reset the timeline
thanks tva that's great that's a
valid excuse i like to think that that
thanks tva at the end is like
thanks tva now i'm fired
[Music]
up thanks dba uh catherine said
why does loki buy cough drops because he
doesn't want a thor throat
oh my god catherine magnificent
and then uh a serious question here
taylor asks do you guys think that there
will be some kind of thor or even a
friega cameo
also congrats on the wedding mt did you
get married to miss minutes
thank you i mean obviously yes and i
took her last name so
it's almost right that's right
i should remember have i forgotten uh
my bad but yeah uh i i don't know about
a thor cam i mean technically we have
seen a thor into freaking cameo through
archive footage but
beyond that i maybe afrika cameo
i don't know if they're gonna get chris
hemsworth in the show but
renee russo i could see showing up i
mean for your cameo i think is
highly highly probable because they
showed frigate in that um
little flashback sequence i think that
that's gonna be a thing but like later
on thor
maybe we'll see a thor variant but yeah
maybe not chris hemsworth because
that's a high oh an alternate thought
yeah do you think we'd see uh
his brother the actor like luke
hemsworth playing uh
thor ultimate timeline amazing
i would love that well again check out
all of our great loki merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
uh but empty what's our first question
our first question of the day is
wait a damn minute who is lady loki and
what is her true plan
yes good question well a short answer
trying to do the shorter answers in here
obviously bombing the secret timeline
but i think that's just one part of the
plan
the real plan i believe is to actually
clear the tda so that she can hold the
timekeepers hostage
make some changes to their sacred
timeline to set her up nice but
let's back up uh lady loki we all pretty
much guessed from
fluid showing up as loki's sex on that
uh case file in episode one
that this mystery loki variant would
probably be lady loki now in the comics
lady loki isn't so much loki from an
alternate timeline she's
really the spirit of loki reincarnated
into a female body
after the ragnarok event it was a body
made for lady sith
but loki to kind of screw with thor a
little bit just went into that body uh
and then lived on his lady loki so it's
not like we just tried to come up with
like a girl version of this
it's still loki but now the uh the sex
identity is that of a woman what an
interesting prank
it's like i'm going to become a woman
that's right my brother thor
right i mean yeah it's fun it's but it's
also very on brand for loki right
um but in the mcu's case i think we can
assume from sophia du martino's
character
her horned crown her common bond with
loki that this is
indeed the mcu's version of loki just
looking from an alternate branch
timeline
but she must be a past variant who has
managed to avoid being erased by the tva
because she's been at this for some time
before
this branch l130 loki came into
existence
so um maybe her past timeline was pruned
but she was not the way that our branch
loki i think
we saw that reset charge go off in
mongolia that timeline was pruned
but look he's just out of time with the
tva in the same way that i think lady
loki is out of time
but not within tva custody she's been
hiding in these various apocalyptic
eras now a lot of people are asking but
why is she female like what does that
mean
well loki's sex is just indeed fluid and
i think he
explained the difference between
duplication casting illusion projection
right as we were learning different
loki's of slightly different powers and
in her case
she can transfer her consciousness into
different bodies and project her
consciousness into another host while
she
goes about her business in her own body
so i'm thinking maybe that female body
may have been just a random woman that
this loki's spirit
overtook and decided to stay inside of
which actually would be pretty similar
to that comic's backstory if you think
about it oh my god
i love that idea what i didn't even
consider that it's like that couldn't
even be the true loki
what that's a good right and the same
way that there was like
another loki that looks like tom
hiddleston this is just like a body that
she jumped to do and it's still loki's
soul and identity just carrying this
this vessel you know oh [ __ ] what if
it's richard e grant bro
hey now you're thinking baby yo
that richard grant is controlling her as
a puppet yeah
three tiered puppet layer it's it's
really just a pyramid scheme
and it's the illuminati eye and it's all
connected it goes all the way to the top
we do see like a sort of image like that
in the credits right with the uh with
the variant i think there's like a one
um stick figure in the circle and then
we have the branches
so what if that one in the middle is
like i'm richard e grant and like i have
these little
that's a really good idea i love it i
love it that's what we're doing we're
all faking on the fly we just watched
the episode and we're
trying to unpack we're figuring it out
in real time now
um we also have to note mt it sounds
like lady loki might be telepathic
like in addition to be able to touch
someone's temple and control their minds
there's that moment when she lowers her
hood you hear all these voices echoing
around
what is this about this isn't about you
and if you listen closely it sounds like
you hear tom hiddleston saying
what do you want and what is this about
and then she answers that question by
saying this isn't about you
this might be just another layer to her
powers because we don't
i don't think we heard loki scream out
loud what is this about that might have
just been a panic in his brain that he
was trying to hide
by putting on a brave face and she could
read into his brain just be like
you can't hide anything from me it's
such a different power set than the loki
that we know
because like yeah he cannot do that like
the only mind control he could have done
is through the mind stone when he had it
in eventually one
and like that's right it's just i'm just
wondering how varied
these power sets are for each loki
because like we we do get a glimpse of
those
little uh holographic projection that uh
mobius had uh before their little heist
and so we see a big loki and we see like
different variations like how
different are these powers which is so
interesting it sounds pretty different
it's not just like slight variations on
a theme these are completely different
forms of sorcery you know
i wonder if it's just loki or like you
know thor as well in different universes
like is
is there like different power sets for
thor like it's just so interesting to me
it does match with your line of thinking
mt that this could be a
very very old loki that's just picked up
various forms of sorcery because loki
learned those sorcery skills this is
true
over time he wasn't necessarily born
with those skills that was a learned
kind of magic
so because it's not like all frost
giants or sorcerers you know
so i think this could just be an older
loki that's picked up additional skills
i mean we've already seen this loki do
things that he wasn't able to do before
he
used telekinesis to summon a roomba you
know that wasn't
something we ever had seen loki do in
the mcu i don't think
right yeah i've never seen that before
so like and we know in trailer footage
he uses a green energy blast to like
blast someone the way like
wanda maximoff could i don't recall him
doing that
there's all kinds of news getting these
new powers gradually throughout the
series because
or maybe he's getting them from lady
loki throughout this fight she's
powering him up as a partner you know
and just teaching him
unlocking new skills for him and that's
kind of the temptation the lure the
reason
he follows her through that time door oh
my god that'd be so sick
slogan getting new powers like sort of
mandalorian style i dig it yeah
well let's talk about her plan let's
talk about her plan she's obviously been
stealing
both reset charges and tva portal
opening devices
uh and now she's merging both of these
like dozens of them
uh and loki correctly deduced that this
variant has been hiding in apocalypses
uh that includes this rockstar disaster
of 2050
and uh the reason she's been hiding
there isn't so that she can
you know replenish her resources from
this big costco it's so that it's this
big warehouse space with a lot of
shelves that she can hide stuff in
in case she's ever found and she can
gradually just like
nestle something behind the tv screens
behind the roombas behind the plants
and just kind of go undetected so that
she can do this all at the same time
because she needed to be able to
synchronize all this
i love that whole apocalypse angle it's
like hiding in the apocalypse like
no one would think about that it's just
right such a good hiding spot
and an apocalypse in the year 2050
there's all kinds of weird gadgets and
gizmos all over this store no one's
going to look twice at something that
looks like just some kind of other radio
equipment versus if you try to do this
in pompeii
or on asgard or something like that
people can be like the hell is this what
the [ __ ] is this
technology yeah so really this is all a
stalling game right like she just
popped her mind to b15 to all these
other different people just to like give
her enough time to sync it all up but
really she's doing this to
rig up all these dozens of charges
dropping throughout time and space uh
but yeah it includes like new york in
1947
interesting year that i'll be looking
into in the breakdown asgard in 2004
what was happening there
the cree home world of holla in the year
51 a.d now we know the cree are much
older than humanity
uh and they kind of stopped their
evolution at like thousands of years
before us so what happened in 51 ad
on holla to make lady loki choose that
one or was it just random i
i have to think it's all deliberate yeah
i think it's deliberate too because you
have to remember with the creed there's
this
like a really long war between the korea
and zandar what if that has to do with
that who knows
um today to stabilize it right so
obviously yeah this is a crisis that
threatens to destabilize the entire
sacred timeline in very specific ways
but the real threat i believe is yet to
come because the kidnapped crota monitor
says right before this happens that lady
loki now knows the location of the
timekeepers
something that ren slayers seem to have
as privileged information and then
rensselaer in particular watches
in horror as all these minutemen are
rushing off to prune the branches
and she arms herself and she probably
realized that lady loki
is coming to her and that she really
wanted to flush out
all these tva agents to leave the tva
undefended
so that lady loki can sneak into the tva
and find the timekeepers
and we know from the trailer footage
that lady loki does infiltrate this
place we don't know how far she'll get
but the end credits remember teased that
one floor
one ej that said access denied
that could be the chamber where the
timekeepers or whatever the timekeepers
actually are are kept and we'll talk a
little bit later this episode about what
rand slayer might be hiding about the
true nature of the time keepers but my
theory for now is that lady loki plans
to find these timekeepers to hold them
hostage or at least to force them
to amend the sacred timeline so that the
sacred timeline loki who'd still exist
by the way he's continuing on to asgard
in the impending saga history that we
knew before
that guy's still there i think she wants
to change that sacred timeline
so that loki gets replaced with this
lady loki or whoever is controlling her
so that they no longer have to be a
fugitive that the world is theirs
but i also suspect that whenever lady
loki gets there she's gonna realize that
the time keepers are less of the divine
forces that she thought
it's gonna be kind of like a wizard of
oz scenario and the wizard of oz can't
really give the seeker exactly what
they're asking
for he can't give someone courage he
gives someone a big medal
you know so i think that's what she's
gonna find
that you know she's on her own story
circle
and once you get what you think you want
you get disappointed and your goals
change
oh man like i do like ever since you
brought it up like that wizard of oz
angle has been like just in my head
because i love it i love
twists like that i think that the the
idea of clearing out the minutemen so
that lady loki can infiltrate is right
on the money there
because like there's just so many of
them in there that like
actually getting to the timekeepers
would be impossible so like she's just
making them all busy
like keeping them busy so that she can
go in and do that thing
though i think that lady loki i just
think that she just hates the idea of
being controlled
by fate personally i think the
timekeepers are real she just wants to
destroy the concept of
one timeline because she's like i don't
like the fact that like
we're just stuck here like let let it
all just go let it just be chaos look
because the loki is an agent of chaos
and they say that word repeatedly
throughout this episode and i believe
episode one as well so it's just like
i think that she likes chaos and wants
the the multiverse of madness to
to occur just because it means freedom
agreed and i think uh
all the loki's kind of believe that on a
philosophical level that they
thrive in situations of chaos so i think
that is their
kind of their super objective right is
to have just uh situations
that are the most chaotic but on a more
specific level i think she targeted
these very specific dates
one by one to find uh the moment in that
place's history where they're at kind of
a fork in the road
and then they went the fork in the road
that led to the history but they it was
kind of those watershed moments right
uh to create a specific nexus thing that
would be
even harder the most difficult mess for
the minutemen to clean up in that
scenario so i bet if you look at each
one of those dates you'll see
oh you know what there was kind of a
nexus point it things could have gone in
another direction there
and that's why she chose the specific
dates to make it specifically
impossible to patch goddamn lady loki
you are one conniving
smart mastermind woman she's been at
this for a long time you have plenty of
time to plan it
i bet you know uh given enough time any
of us can be
the monster the multiverse i wonder how
long she's been doing this for
because like time moves differently
there so like she's been she could be
doing this for like hundreds of years
who knows
decades yes millennia for sure um
so where there's a lot more to discuss
from this episode first we want to thank
some people who helped us make it
starting with our friends at warby
parker so warby parker is committed to
providing exceptional vision care online
and in stores offering eyeglasses
sunglasses eye exams and contact lenses
glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses sunglasses
progressives and blue light
lenses are also available need help
choosing frames we'll take the quiz
answer a few quick questions and they'll
suggest some great looking glasses that
are totally personalized
to fit your face and your style i took
their quiz and ordered a home try on kit
specifically for sunglasses to protect
my beepers this summer
i really like the process because it
allowed me to try on very different
styles of glasses and see not only what
fit and look best but
also what got the seal of approval from
folks around me with better sense of
style who are gonna have to look at the
space
warby parker sunglasses feature premium
polarized lenses that are scratch
resistant and provide 100 uv protection
and you can get the sunglasses with your
prescription so try warby parker's free
home try on program order five
pairs of glasses and try at home for
free for five days
there's no obligation to buy ships free
and includes a prepaid return
shipping label try five pairs of glasses
at home for free at warbyparker.com
marvel we also want to thank keeps for
sponsoring this episode more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness and there are only two
fda approved medications that prevent
hair loss
well good news keeps offers both of them
keeps has a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair i personally hate going
to the doctor's appointments for
anything
it's never had a convenient time you
have to park you got to sit in a waiting
room
it's about as much fun as losing your
hair is yeah
keeps offers convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home or go
to the doctor or the pharmacy
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
to keep the costs
low their proven results arrive to your
doorstep in discrete packaging
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors with hair loss
prevention is the key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you gotta act fast and
if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash marvel
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
marvel to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash marvel and we
wanna thank
credit karma money for sponsoring this
episode we all like instant
gratification with credit karma money
you could win cash reimbursements for
debit purchases
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
up to five
thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card and if you win you'll be
notified on the spot and your instant
karma cash will be added back to your
spend account
credit karma money has already given
away over three million dollars in
instant karma to 50 000 credit karma
members
open your fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirements no overdraft fees and free
withdrawals from a network of over 50
000 atms
so right now visit creditkarma.com win
money to
open your free account and start winning
instant karma go to creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money insta karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms supplies c rules
banking services provided by mvb bank
inc member fdic maximum balance and
transfer limits apply
so empty our next wait a day a minute
where
are the time keepers and do you think
rentslayer is telling the truth about
them
well i i personally do think that
rentslayer is telling the truth about
the timekeepers and that the timekeepers
do exist
though you know i'm not 100 sure because
like
in this in this episode they do talk
about the the idea of
you know belief and like you know belief
in a higher power sort of because like
you know
the the humans believe in in gods like
the asgardians and like
the asgardians don't really believe in
any other gods above them so this
this idea of the time keepers being
introduced it's like they could not
be real they could very well not be real
or they could be what i believe to be
the mcu's take on
a marvel group of beings called those
who
sit above in shadow and if you guys are
familiar with this in the comics they're
basically the
the gods gods of the asgardians and like
they they take the energies of of
ragnarok
to sustain them into they feed off of
that energy but i think marvel studios
could be taking the time keepers and
this concept of
those who um sit above in shadow smoosh
them together
and uh could be using the time keepers
as as this force that uses the forces
from
you know each timeline each each
rotation of
the mcu throughout time to sustain
themselves
no i like that idea that might be why
they have the sacred timeline it's kind
of like an energy beam a stream
that feeds them and with with a
multiverse they don't uh
get a nice hearty meal they just snack
throughout the day and that doesn't
sustain them as well and we see in the
trailers and the promo material
we see that like that rainbow like
stream um around that rock thing
and i you know i i think that that's the
timeline that they they uh suck energy
from
no i like that idea a lot empty i want
to clear something up when i'm saying
that like the
the time keepers might be part of some
suspicious
uh nature i'm not saying they don't
exist that someone's just lying about
their existence
i'm just saying they aren't the exact
gods that miss minutes said they are
like that they're because in the comics
they were they were artificial they were
constructed
by someone and that's what i think is
happening in the show that there's
someone else who is controlling them or
someone else who built them
but i'm not saying that they're they're
not in existence at all
obviously i think they exist i just
think that someone else is pulling the
strings together
so that's why i'm saying they're not
real i'm just saying they're puppeted
they're there there's something there
but like when she says the timekeepers i
think she
is referring to a more complex story
there than what we saw in the miss
minutes cartoon
because rinse later like the fact that
uh moby has said he's never actually
seen them
you know only rent slayer or maybe a
couple other people have actually seen
them
i think when we actually see them it's
not gonna be exactly what we have seen
in these statues and in the cartoon
it's there's just gonna be something
more to them uh and i think it might
just be like a little man who looks like
richard e grant
behind a curtain who's pulling a bunch
of levers or whatever it is you know
uh or someone who's like i created these
things they're now out of my control
you know there's just more to that story
and i think we're hinting more and more
of that in this episode
uh and i think that secret is what bran
slayer is more afraid of getting exposed
um the fact that things are redacted in
the end credits there there are lies
there are secrets there's cover-ups
there's
all kinds of things to the tva story and
their agenda
that ren slayer doesn't want getting out
there and i think that's what lady loki
wants to expose
i feel like that makes sense given what
we do know about this you know
we don't know a lot about the
multiversal war but let's say that there
was a war
and that the aliens and all that stuff
fought in this war
what if regular alien people won they
became these timekeepers they have this
like you know
access to this power but like they're
just regular people you know and
i do okay now i see what you're talking
about with the whole oz element because
they could
just be just regular just not all that
powerful people
but like they're just boosting up their
myth so it's like yeah we're awesome
we're pretty cool
you should respect us don't even wonder
what we're doing behind
the closed doors in the same way that
like uncle sam
is uh it's a symbol you know those
symbols are very real to people they
matter to people they inspire people
they mean things exactly uh but like it
doesn't mean that there is a giant uncle
sam who's going to drag you and force
you to go to war
you know i'd like to think that there's
a giant uncle sam mech
that we
you're fighting uh yeah that's
essentially what he is though
it's just really what that is it's draft
boards mr potter from it's wonderful
life water
some crazy old withered man in a
wheelchair and that's what judy grant is
that's what i've just believed in my
life experience that everyone pulling
the levers of power is such a
terrifyingly old man who should have
died decades ago all right what's our
next question
our next question is wait a damn minute
what is miss minutes exactly a recording
an ai
or something else like my wife yeah
there was that interesting moment where
uh loki was swatting her with the rolled
up jet ski magazine he's like what
exactly are you are you listening to me
right now
yeah and also what's weird about her is
she's a function on
that she's a selectable function on that
device like
in the elevator you can also push a
button what does it mean to push a miss
minutes button
does that mean she's gonna pop out as a
holoprojection that moment be like what
do you name me for
friends and then like kick people in the
knees and giggle and run away
like what the hell is she i'm wondering
if she is a living
uh artificial intelligence right she's
not a recording obviously she's
responsive in the moment she could
either be sorcery or technology i'm
leaning towards she's tva technology
uh and in the way that like the cree
supreme intelligence
was kind of this advanced advanced
technology that controlled
everything in that uh civilization i
think that could be what miss minutes is
she could even be some kind of program
that is tied with the time keepers
uh she is the public face of the time
keepers in a way
uh to where she's it's kind of cute easy
to digest
thing but the more and more you start to
pull at the threads of her
she's like i'm not gonna give you any
answers sort of hey
show some manners and she'll jump back
into her little computer
but yeah i think uh she's kind of like
the tva equivalent of the crease supreme
intelligence that's
my theory at least that okay interesting
what i also found interesting is that
she did dodge loki
every time he tried to hit her right
yeah he wasn't able to make contact with
her yeah yeah but like
i would assume that she was just like
this projection that he could just like
zoom through so like why did she feel
the need to hop around
and then not just hide into the computer
like i wonder why she felt that need
yeah i know does she feel pain yeah like
is this is she running on some type of
like hard light technology that makes
her physically real like it's
very interesting to me i wonder why she
does yeah i think it's like uh
like almost like genie magic like genies
are just smoke but they don't want you
putting your hand through them or ghosts
the same way like that feels weird to do
it it's rude
uh and it's disrespectful and i think
respect matters a lot to her
exactly i mean i would know more than
most um because i've been kicked out of
the house and uh
a couple of times sleeping on the couch
because of accidental disrespect
we'll do that again yep sorry we'll do
that okay sorry boo-boo
empty i want to ask you another question
yes wait a damn minute
who is justice rentslayer's other
mystery analyst that she keeps on the
side
depending oh yeah roosevelt high school
pins yes we're definitely gonna get um
some more information on that
in the future because like they just
they're obviously setting that up
i don't think that it's another mystery
analyst i have this weird feeling that
rents layer
has like a secret life on the side i
think that you know that that pet is
probably from like a i don't know
like parent teacher conference and she
has like a daughter she's like hey
my daughter's in high school and like
here's her pen from that thing that we
did oh
cool she's secretly like you know
breaking the rules even though she's
like this like
i love the rules all this stuff like she
has a secret thing because
it's just bureaucracy all day every day
like she needs purpose
so i have a feeling that that's what
that's about but i don't know
i like that idea a lot um yeah i think
the fact that it's franklin d roosevelt
high school
high schools didn't start getting named
after fdr until
probably what after world war ii i would
say so that kind of places
whatever that point in the timeline is
from
1940s late 1940s onward yeah
and i'm wondering if that other analyst
could be some other kind of past analyst
that she's kind of hush-hush about that
could be her loved one
immortus aka kang the conqueror uh and
that could have been
some because i keep clinging to this as
a member of the kang gang
mtv i love this idea that kang could
have been a member of the tva an agent a
former director of it one of the time
keepers someone involved with the tva
to have been involved with rent slayer
in the past and that rent slayer
isn't proud of it but she has this
ongoing affection for this person
who went rogue whether by stealing one
of the power stones from the evidence
locker
or time stones from the evidence locker
and going crazy uh could have been some
other variant
uh that she just let go uh and this is
just something that she keeps as a
symbol of it because clearly she has a
um
some kind of friendship at least with
mobius
but like he has a familiarity with her
and she even gives him more leeway than
she probably would another
analyst you know but the fact that she's
not telling him about that
shows that there are barriers between
them
they could have chosen any tva character
in the comics they chose renslayer
you know it's just is it just like a
random character or
is it is that kang connection important
i think that it is probably going to be
important because they don't just choose
names like that for no reason i think
that that is going to be significant i
think you are barking up a very good
tree
we have a few more questions we want to
talk about but one more person helped us
make this episode
thank you to magic spoon for sponsoring
us lots of us are trying to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring right
well magic spoon has the amazing flavors
that you love but without all the bad
stuff
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving that's only 140 calories a
serving
it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free
order yourself a variety pack that comes
with four flavors cocoa fruity frosted
and peanut butter get wild and mix up
some of the cocoa and peanut butter
flavors in the same bowl kind of tastes
like a peanut butter cup just
imagine the flavor combinations so go to
magicspoon.com
marvel to grab a variety pack and try it
today and be sure to use our promo code
marvel at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal magicspoon.com
marvel and use the code marvel to save
five dollars off and thank you to magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
now empty i have another question for
you wait a damn minute how does the tva
compare
in terms of power status to other marvel
deities things like celestials uh the
watchers galactus the elders
uh because we had this whole moment of
like them comparing their belief systems
like what is god to them how do you
think the time keepers line up with all
that
we actually did a big question on this
me and marina um that should be coming
out
really soon and i can't wait to see that
i met marina for the first time then
she's great so yeah you should yeah
um but yeah anyway yeah no uh so the tva
is very much
up there on the marvel hierarchy um
because they they
essentially live outside of the universe
outside of time and space in a lot of
you know the marvel hierarchy exist
within the marvel universe and so since
they
exist outside of that and they have
authority over the marvel universe
then that means that you know though
your beings like the you know celestials
in in in your your watchers and all that
they have you know a higher jurisdiction
than that that is
um what i believe to be the the
hierarchy there but what do you think
eric
i mean obviously the tva has some
formidable power for sure the fact that
uh
within the tva magic doesn't really work
the infinity stones aren't
usable in that boundary uh it just
depends what the ultimate source of the
tva powers
is is it the timekeepers themselves is
there some force beyond the timekeepers
of the tv that really supplies the power
but the fact they can trump as guardians
is a pretty big deal
uh or in this case frost giants it makes
me believe that they'd probably be able
to
arrest eternals like thanos and the
other for sure
i don't know if they'd be able to beat
the celestials just because the
celestials can kind of do
anything see i i think that they could
easily do that i think that like in a
scenario yeah
where like they let's say that they
wanted to arrest a celestial they would
like
arrest him and they he would the
celestial will come in in like the same
size and form as a human being
because like you know yeah like i feel
like a lot of the celestial power
comes from being rooted inside of a
universe and like
once you take anything powerful like the
infinity stones or
you know a celestial or whatever out of
their native universe all of their power
becomes inert
that that's why loki could use his magic
like all
anything that you could do in inside the
main marvel
or whatever universe you come from
that's that's done because i feel like
the tva
has sort of like has the same authority
as the living tribunal like i think
they're on the same level
but like different you know departments
and [ __ ]
so like you know i i do feel like
celestials and galactus and your
watchers and all that
would would probably be as depowered as
loki in that scenario
they usually fall within their cosmic
purpose so like you wouldn't see
a celestial or galactus in the tva
because
they're serving their universal function
no that's a good argument
empty um because like it's so hard to
compare the power statuses of things
like eternity
you know to kronos because they're all
just like
living embodiments of abstract ideas
yeah
and they it's not really even possible
for them to wage war against each other
because it's like the way it's set up in
marvel comics like living tribunal is
kind of the ultimate legal authority
you know and if you think of the tva as
like a legal institution
uh with courts and judges and
prosecutors and things like that
it seems like they would probably fall
right underneath the living tribunal i
don't think they're above the living
tribunal
uh living tribunals like the supreme
court justice and then the tba is like
the
you know an appellate court that's right
underneath exactly that's a good idea
but that appellate court can prosecute
anyone like in the american legal system
you know pretty much anyone is supposed
to be under the law
unless you have a very interesting
interpretation
of the second article the constitution
as some of our recent presidents have
um but we won't get into that here
that will be a different podcast uh
series
channel in the future where i'm allowed
to be political
inside politics well
that will be it for this episode of
inside marvel
uh the next video on the channel will be
the easter egg breakdown all the little
details you missed in episode two
now next week uh some personal
stuff has come up that i have to go
handle so i'm not gonna be here for
inside marvel
but uh we have a special guest up here
with mt
so stay tuned for that and uh throughout
this week you're gonna see plenty of
wonderful loki videos so
hold on your butt be sure to subscribe
to new rockstars check out our
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me
at eavos follow mt mastertainment thank
you for watching we'll close with our
favorite moment of the episode
i installed that reset charge as well
shhh
[Music]
you